MIDDAY TODAY?
RAYMOND ARROYO BREAKS THAT ONE
ALL DOWN.
BUT FIRST, AMERICA IN SHUTDOWN,
DAY 17.
BEYOND THE NUMBERS THAT FLASHED
ON THE SCREEN, COUNTING THOSE
INFECTED AND KILLED BY COVID-19,
AND THEY ARE ALWAYS HORRIFIC, WE
OFTEN FORGET THROUGH THE SADNESS
AND THE FEAR THAT THIS IS ALSO
CAUSING AMERICANS -- OUR
AMERICAN FAMILY A LOT OF PAIN.
WE HAVE TO ASK WHAT IS THIS
VIRUS DOING TO US AS A PEOPLE AS
WE DEAL WITH THE VICTIMS AND
TRYING TO PREVENT MORE DEATHS?
WELL, APPARENTLY, IT’S TURNING
US INTO A NATION OF SNITCHES.
>> IF YOU’VE OBSERVED RECURRING
VIOLATIONS OF THE STAY-AT-HOME
ORDER, PLEASE CONTINUE TO LET US
KNOW, CoronavirusAtL.A.City
CoronavirusAtL.A.City.org/BUSI
NESS VIOLATION.
YOU KNOW THE OLD EXPRESSION
ABOUT SNITCHES.
IN THIS CASE, SNITCHES GET
REWARDS.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR TURNING
FOLKS IN AND MAKING SURE WE ARE
ALL SAFE.
>> Laura: I HAVE A QUESTION.
WHO KEEPS US SAFE FROM YOU?
IT’S BECOME ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
THAT IN THE MIDST OF THIS
UNPRECEDENTED HEALTH CRISIS THAT
THERE ARE BAD ACTORS EVERYWHERE
TRYING TO USE THIS TO THEIR
ADVANTAGE.
SEAN AND I WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT SOME OF THEM.
FROM WASHED UP CELEBRITIES
LIP-SYNCHING THEIR GREATEST HITS
ON YOUTUBE TO POLITICIANS USING
FEAR TO CRAMDOWN POLICIES THAT
WOULD BE INCONCEIVABLE TO US
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHILE WE AS A NATION CONTINUE
DOING OUR PART TO KEEP THE
OURSELVES AND EACH OTHER SAFE, W
CANNOT STAND IDLY BY AS PEOPLE
IN EITHER PARTY TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS VERY COMPLICATED AND
DIRE SITUATION.
>> AS A SOCIETY, BEYOND JUST
THIS IMMEDIATE SITUATION, WE
SHOULD START LOOKING FORWARD TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS EXPERIENCE
IS GOING TO CHANGE US, OR HOW IT
SHOULD CHANGE US.
BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO BE
TRANSFORMATIVE.
WONDER WE GET BACK TO NORMAL?
I DON’T THINK WE GET BACK TO
NORMAL.
>> Laura: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT,
WAIT, WAIT A SECOND.
WE DON’T GET BACK TO NORMAL?
I THOUGHT THE WHOLE POINT OF
LOCKING OURSELVES IN OUR HOMES
WAS TO SAVE LIVES, OF COURSE,
AND THEN GO BACK TO OUR OLD
NORMAL LIVES.
THE DEMOCRATS THINK THEY HAVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN A NO-WIN
SITUATION, THAT’S OBVIOUS FROM
THE WAY THEY ARE ACTING, SO THEY
ARE EVEN WORRIED AT THIS POINT
ABOUT HIDING THEIR AGENDA.
>> ARE YOU TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION GREEN JOBS, GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE?
>> YES, AND IF WE ARE GOING TO
DO INFRASTRUCTURE, WE NEED IT
BIG, WE NEED IT BOLD AND WE
NEEDED FUTURISTIC, WHICH MEANS
GREEN.
THERE’S TRADITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE, ROADS, BRIDGES,
HIGHWAYS, WE NEED THAT, BUT WE
ALSO NEED NEW GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE FUTURE.
>> Laura: PHASE FOUR, COVID
MEETS SOLYNDRA.
MAYBE WE CAN CALL IT COVINDRA.
ABSOLUTELY ABSURD AND THEY
SHOULD BE EXPOSED AND RESISTED
AT ALL COSTS BY THE G.O.P.
COME ON.
IF THEY’RE NOT GOING GREEN
THOUGH, THEY ARE GOING THE GUNS.
BECAUSE THE SAME LIBERAL
GOVERNORS WHO CLASSIFIED
ABORTION CLINICS AS ESSENTIAL
BUSINESSES RUSHED IN TO CLOSE
GUN STORES AND NONESSENTIAL.
IT GUN OWNERS, THEY WEREN’T
HAPPY.
>> WE WERE WILLING TO JUST SIT
BY -- THE RIGHT TO KEEP AND BEAR
ARMS NECESSARILY INCLUDES THE
RIGHT TO ACQUIRE THEM.
HOW CAN YOU KEEP, HOW CAN YOU
BEAR SOMETHING YOU CAN’T GET
YOUR HANDS ON?
>> Laura: HERE’S VAUX’S PRECUT
HEADLINE FROM EARLIER TODAY.
FLATTEN THE CURVE AND YOUR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
CHECK THAT OUT.
MAYORS ARE ALSO USING THE VIRUS
TO EMPTY THEIR JAILS.
SOME VIOLENT OFFENDERS HAVE
ALREADY GONE ON TO COMMIT OTHER
CRIMES.
AND SINCE WE’RE TALKING ABOUT
LAWBREAKERS, THEY HAVE ADVOCATES
IN THE WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING ROOM
TOO.
>> OVER 5 MILLION IMMIGRANTS IN
THIS COUNTRY DO PAY TAXES
THROUGH THEIR I.D. NUMBERS YET
THEY WILL NOT RECEIVE ANY MONEY
IN THE STIMULUS PACKAGE.
HOW DO YOU SUPPOSE THEY SURVIVE
DURING THE COVID-19?
>> YOU’RE SAYING UNDOCUMENTED,
MEANING THEY CAME IN ILLEGALLY.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD SAY WE
HAVE A LOT OF CITIZENS RIGHT NOW
THAT WILL BE WORKING, SO, WHAT
ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
IT’S A TOUGH THING.
I’M NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU A HARD
AND FAST ANSWER BECAUSE I JUST
WANT TO TELL YOU IT’S SOMETHING
I THINK ABOUT AND IT’S SOMETHING
WE’RE WORKING ON.
>> Laura: WHILE OF COURSE
EVERYONE FEELS BAD FOR EVERYONE
IN THIS SITUATION HERE AND WE
LOVE IMMIGRANTS, THE OPERATIVE
WORD, AND PRESIDENT TRUMP KNOWS
THIS, HE SAID IT’S ONLY TIMES,
IS "LEGAL" IMMIGRANTS.
RIGHT NOW, WITH EVERYTHING WHERE
FACING IT’S GOT TO BE AMERICANS
FIRST.
BUT OF ALL THE SCAMS PERPETRATED
THROUGH THE COVID NIGHTMARE, THE
EFFORT TO CHANGE VOTING -- WE
TOLD YOU LIKE TWO WEEKS AGO THIS
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
PERHAPS THE WORST.
ANYTHING TO CREATE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BALLOT
HARVESTING OR EVEN VOTER FRAUD.
>> WE NEED $1.6 BILLION ADDED TO
THE NEXT RESPONSE BILL TO ENSURE
THAT VOTE BY MAIL, IN PERSON,
EARLY VOTING AND ELECTION DAY
VOTING CAN HAPPEN.
>> WE WILL PROBABLY BE MOVING TO
VOTE BY MAIL.
>> IT MAY MEAN THAT YOU HAVE A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE YOU HAVE
DRIVE IN VOTING, LITERALLY, YOU
PULL UP AND YOU VOTE.
>> Laura: I DON’T EVEN KNOW
WHAT BIDEN WAS SAYING THERE.
KIND OF TRAILS OFF AT THE END OF
THOSE SENTENCES, DOESN’T HE?
BUT IF NOT ALL OF THE DEMOCRATS
PLAYING GAMES HERE.
A FORMER TROUGH ADMINISTRATION
FDA COMMISSIONER -- WELL, HE’S
ACTUALLY SEEING HIS OWN DEMAND
PEAK.
SCOTT GOTTLIEB.
HE’S ON TELEVISION SEVERAL TIMES
A DAY AND HAS THE EAR OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HE’S WRITTEN A KIND OF ROAD MAP
TO RECOVERY PLAN THAT DISCUSSES
THE NEED TO DO A BUNCH OF THINGS
TO GET BACK TO NORMAL, INCLUDING
IN PART TRACKING CITIZENS’
MOVEMENTS DURING THIS CRISIS.
SOME OF THIS IS ALREADY
HAPPENING.
SOURCES TOLD
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" THAT
THE FEDERAL, STATE, AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE ALREADY STARTED
COLLECTING AND STUDYING
GEOLOCATION DATA.
IT TURNS OUT THAT BIG TECH IS
HELPING BIG BROTHER TRACK COVID
COMPLIANCE.
WE EXPECT THIS KIND OF STUFF
FROM CHINA AND RUSSIA, MAYBE
EVEN KOREA, BUT HERE?
WHEN I WAS A STUDENT IN THE
SOVIET UNION, THEY WATCHED OUR
EVERY MOVE.
THERE WERE INFORMANTS IN OUR
HOTEL AND THAT COFFEE -- STAND
UP LITTLE COFFEE SHOPS.
AND THEY ALL RECEIVED SPECIAL
GOVERNMENT PRIVILEGES FOR
RATTING OUT, YOU KNOW, TOURISTS
INTO THE SOVIET UNION OR EVEN
THEIR FELLOW CITIZENS.
MY GOODNESS, WE CAN’T HAVE THAT
HERE.
IN THE COMING DAYS, IN THE
COMING WEEKS, WE ARE GOING TO BE
DOING SOME TRACKING OF OUR OWN,
OF THE MODELS FUNDED BY
BILLIONAIRES THAT KEEP AMERICANS
OUT OF WORK.
PROJECTIONS THAT ARE BASED IN
FAULTY ASSUMPTIONS AND IN SOME
CASES EVEN INCOMPLETE DATA.
CONGRESS MAY BE OUT OF SESSION
WHILE YOU’RE OUT OF WORK, BUT
NOT US.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS DIE EVERY YEAR FROM
HORRIFIC THINGS, VIRUSES,
PNEUMONIA, OBVIOUSLY OLD AGE,
CANCER, DIABETES.
OTHER TERRIBLE ILLNESSES.
THEY ALSO DIE FROM DESPAIR.
DRUG OVERDOSES.
OPIOIDS.
SUICIDES.
AND LONELINESS.
EVERY LIFE IS PRECIOUS AND WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT WINNING THE
WAR AGAINST COVID-19 DOESN’T
KILL THE PATIENT, WHICH IS
AMERICA.